THE MOTOROLA DISASTER:
Remember Motorola?
At one point, they were selling network equipment,
signal amplifiers, and even digital video
recorders.
But, likely the product that they’re most
well known for is cell phones and particularly
this one: the Motorola Razr.
Back in the early 2000s, this phone was ubiquitous
and you can’t forget about the nostalgic
ringtone either.
There was something about the sleek look of
the phone and the premium build that people
just couldn’t get enough of.
You could even argue that it was the status
symbol of the time given that it wasn’t
cheap having launched for $500 or the price
as the original iPhone.
Nonetheless, Motorola went on to sell 130
million units during their hayday.
To this day, the only iPhone that has sold
better is the iPhone 6 and 6+ as a combination.
The bad part about the Razr for Motorola was
that it was basically their peak.
While they had a substantial business outside
of cell phones, their cell phone business
was what was really iconic.
And as we saw the introduction of blackberries
and smartphones, Motorola’s phones quickly
fell out of favor.
They tried to pivot to the smartphone market
themselves, but this wasn’t all that successful
and that brings us to early 2011.
To most, it seemed obvious that Motorola was
on their way out, and that their fate was
similar to that of Blackberry.
Yet, there was one person willing to take
a gamble on Motorola: Google.
In August of 2011, Google agreed to pay $12.5
billion in cash to acquire the waning company.
As you would guess, critics and investors
were rather skeptical with many predicting
that it would be a colossal disaster.
And as fate would have it, that’s exactly
what happened.
Less than three years after the purchase,
Google would end up selling Motorola to Lenovo
for just $2.9 billion.
On paper, this was clearly a massive loss
having cost Google $9.6 billion plus the cost
of running Motorola.
Time would declare that Motorola was a gargantuan
mistake that only Google could afford to make,
and there were several similar articles mocking
Google for their seemingly apparent incompetency.
But with time, people started to see a different
side of the picture and realized what game
Google was really playing.
So, here’s the story of Google’s “worst
acquisition” that actually turned out to
be their best.
LAUNCHING ANDROID:
Hearing that Motorola may have been Google’s
best acquisition is probably hard to believe
at first glance.
After all, Google has had so many successful
acquisitions, and most people would point
to YouTube or Android as being Google’s
best acquisition especially given that both
of them cost substantially less than Motorola.
But, the thing to note is that Motorola actually
played a massive role in Android’s success.
And to really understand this, we’ll have
to take a look back at origins of Android.
The story starts in October of 2003 well before
the launch of the iPhone.
At the time, Android wasn’t even being developed
for smartphones.
It was actually being developed for digital
cameras.
But, the founders quickly realized that the
smartphone space had way more growth potential
and they would pivot which attracted the interest
of Larry Page of Google.
Page could see that the mobile industry was
gaining a lot of steam, and he wanted Google
to be very much involved.
But, Google and Android had a major problem:
they didn’t have any hardware.
Neither of them had any experience building
any hardware and while they tried, it became
clear very early on that they wouldn’t be
able to compete with Apple.
After the iPhone announcement, So, the focus
Android could surely not be about the underwhelming
Google phone.
Rather, the focus of Android had to be about
how it could power thousands of different
phones unlike Apple.
And to make this a reality, Google needed
phone manufacturers on board.
Cue in the Open Handset Alliance in November
of 2007.
This alliance connected network operators,
software developers, component manufacturers,
and device manufacturers who would all support
and embrace android.
As you might’ve guessed, one of the device
manufacturers on board was Motorola.
The Motorola Droid would become the first
phone that ran Android 2.0 out of the box,
but they were by no means the last.
All of Google’s partners would launch phone
after phone running Android, and given that
these phones were generally cheaper and more
customizable than their Apple counterparts,
many would choose Android.
And by 2010, Android would overtake iOS in
terms of total installations.
Meanwhile, Google was pumping out update after
update as there was simply so many features
to add.
And eventually, they would even come out with
their own smartphone: the Google Nexus.
But, while Android was a massive success in
terms of adoption and popularity, there were
two massive clouds looming over the project:
Apple and Microsoft.
These two had dominated the OS space for decades
on the computer side of things, and they very
much wanted to extend this monopoly into mobile
space.
So, they would leverage all the patents that
they had accumulated over the decades and
start suing hell out of Google.
LEGAL ONSLAUGHT:
Google didn’t really have an easy way out
of these lawsuits.
The truth was that Google probably was infringing
on a bunch of patents from Apple and Microsoft.
And the fact that Android was open source
just made it easier for these companies to
scover through the code and pinpoint infringements,
and that’s exactly what they did.
This quote from Steve Jobs is probably all
you need to understand Apple’s stance on
the situation.
“I will spend my last dying breath if I
need to, and I will spend every penny of Apple's
$40 billion in the bank, to right this wrong.
I'm going to destroy Android, because it's
a stolen product.
I'm willing to go thermonuclear war on this."
While Microsoft approached the situation more
professionally, I’m sure they had similar
beliefs internally given that they would also
sue Google.
At first, Google and their partners tried
to countersue Apple and Microsoft and win
in court.
After all, it’s not like they didn’t have
resources themselves.
But, this didn’t turn out all that favorably
for them as jurys would start ruling against
them.
Take Apple’s case against Samsung for example.
The jury ended up awarding Apple $1.049 billion
in damages.
Meanwhile, Samsung’s counter lawsuit was
awarded $0 in damages.
This was a massive win for Apple.
Apple won more money from Samsung than Equifax
had to pay for leaking the social security
numbers of a 140 million people.
That’s definitely quite messed up, but Google
wasn’t even worried about the financial
consequences.
If Apple or Microsoft were willing to settle
for $5 or $10 billion, Google probably would’ve
taken the deal.
But, the problem was that Apple and Microsoft
didn’t care about the cash either, they
had plenty of cash themselves.
They were in it for the marketshare.
They’re goal was to shut down Android by
suing Google.
And given that courts were starting to side
with Apple, this made Google very nervous.
Clearly, Steve Jobs wasn’t wiling to meet
in the middle, so Google only had one option:
fight fire with fire.
Instead of focusing on how they could defend
Android, Google would shift their focus onto
how they could attack Apple.
And very quickly, one option became very clear.
You see, while Apple was creating all this
commotion about Google ripping off iOS with
Android, they themselves had a history of
ripping off other companies and were dealing
with lawsuits themselves.
One company that had a bunch of dirt on Apple
was Motorola.
Over the years, they had accumulated 17,000
patents relating to wireless communications,
networks, antennas, cellular communications,
and who knows what else.
They also had 7,500 patents pending.
On top of this, Motorola already suing Apple
on several fronts, and they were winning.
One victory even allowed them to prevent Apple
from selling iPhones in Germany until they
removed a wireless feature from the phone.
For Google, this was a grand slam and they
were willing to pay any monetary price.
DEFENDING ANDROID:
Motorola knew what Google was trying to do
and they weren’t exactly against it.
The truth was, while they were pulling off
some victories against Apple, their business
was dying and they were very much ready to
cash out.
They very much knew their worth though and
played hard ball with Google.
At first, Google was looking to buy the company
for high $20 per share, but Motorola would
work them up to $40 per share.
This was way more than the business was worth,
and that’s why Google received so much heat
for this.
But, as we discussed, Google couldn’t care
less about Motorola’s business, they were
interested in their intellectual property
and this is what they would keep.
When Google sold Motorola to Lenovo, they
would keep all but 2,000 patents.
And this is when Apple and Microsoft finally
realized that Google wasn’t gonna let go
either.
Just three months after Google sold the remains
of Motorola, Apple would settle with Google,
and the duo would agree to drop all patent
litigations against each other.
Microsoft would hold out for quite a bit longer,
but they too would eventually come to their
senses.
If Google was able to just save Android by
flipping Motorolla for a $9.6 billion loss,
that itself would’ve been worth it given
that Android is now the most popular operating
system in the entire world, but it gets even
better for Google.
You see, $2.91 billion sale to Lenovo wasn’t
the only sale that Google was able to make
with Motorola.
They were also able to sell Motorola’s set-top
box unit to Arris for $2.35 billion reducing
their total loss to $7.24 billion, but it
doesn’t stop right there either.
Right after Google bought Motorola, they were
able to rollover a bunch of Motorola’s previous
losses onto their financial statement yielding
them a tax benefit of $6.6 billion.
So, really, Google’s total out of pocket
cost to acquire Motorola’s entire patent
library and defend Android was a mere $640
million.
For perspective, Google made about $79 billion
in the last 12 month period.
So, the whole Motorola ordeal cost them just
3 days worth of net income.
Not to mention, they got to keep 22,500 patents
and applications which works out to less than
$29,000 per patent.
They can use these patents to not only develop
new devices and technologies, but they can
use them to defend the company and even go
on the offensive.
VICTORY:
In the end, while the Motorola acquisition
seemed stupid at the time given the company’s
fundamentals, there was clearly more to it
than just that.
Google brilliantly leveraged Motorola’s
extensive patent library to protect one of
their biggest assets: Android.
And they didn’t end up paying all that much
out of pocket either at the end of the day.
Critics argue that Google likely could’ve
defended Android even without Motorola.
While Apple was making some progress against
Android, it’s unlikely that Apple would’ve
been able to shut down Android altogether.
So, maybe the better play was to just let
Apple play their games and eventually just
settle in court.
But, that likely would’ve been a lot more
expensive.
If Apple was able to win $1 billion from Samsung,
imagine how much they might’ve been able
to win against Google.
Not to mention, Google wouldn’t have acquired
an arsenal of patents for dirt cheap prices
if they went that route.
Now, you could definitely argue that Android
itself was a better acquisition because if
they hadn’t bought Android, there would’ve
been nothing to protect in the first place.
And while that is true, Motorola remains their
biggest acquisition to this day and it’s
by far their most underrated and strategic.
And that makes Motorola Google’s most interesting
acquisition for me, but that’s just what
I think.
Did you know about this massive war between
Apple, Google, and Microsoft?
Comment that down below.
Also, drop a like if you’re a fan of open
source software.
And of course, consider checking out our discord
community to suggest future video ideas and
consider subscribing to see more questions
logically answered.